well in all movies you really have to
shoot it the way that they do in this
movie if this is your first time joining
us we are talking about uh this week's
honest trailer we're giving you our
behind the scenes and more general
thoughts and feelings about the film
we're gonna watch it together and call
out things uh you may have missed and
then we're going to show you some
deleted scenes and answer your questions
and comments so keep those coming in the
live chat and then we'll tease you
beyond what lon just said with next
week's honest trailer that that if you
got it based on that that's based on a
forearm grasp
at one point a guy grabs another guy by
the arm that does happen i swear um so
we should probably do much like this
film we're talking about it has multiple
disclaimers up front to not offend uh i
guess the british rogers feelings and
then also uh that no actual animals were
harmed considering there's an entire
i don't know uh emperor's menagerie of
beasts
they brought prince ali's full
collection
but i think that we should probably get
out up front that like
none of us
watch bollywood hollywood
south asian cinema
really
for me at all uh until this movie i know
nothing i know i am a blank slate when
it comes to this region of the world
right and man did i love this movie
holy crap this was great
uh yeah i'm not i'm not well versed in
in modern indian movies at all i've seen
you know some of the older like classic
stuff you watch in like film school but
not not like this kind of hollywood
bollywood sort of stuff but yeah it was
a it was a real treat it definitely
makes you want i feel like a lot of us
have
an inherent bias against the idea of
these very long movies that combine
action and musicals like that's what we
know in america of bollywood is the
movies are very long and they've always
got a lot of like dance numbers
intermixed with whatever else is going
on and i think that holds a lot of
people back but
this movie being such a crossover hit i
have to feel like it's going to break
down a lot of those barriers this movie
friggin rips it was so awesome um from
the moment that you first see a dude
fight a tiger you're like yes this is
the movie i was meant to be watching my
entire life yeah there are so many
moments that would be the apex like holy
crap moment of an american action movie
but it just hits you with one of those
i'd say every 30
every 20 minutes i'd say there's a
moment where it's like well that would
be the best moment of any american
accent we've talked about this a bunch
lately that it feels like a lot of
american action films have become like
kind of like good enough
like you get some slapping and some
jumping and maybe there's a bit on a
scaffold or whatever we got a quick
little foot chase or i don't know some
parkour yeah like we're in like a little
like a little italian or european city
with narrow streets and there's a guy on
a motorcycle and you know like you get
like we know what those seeds are like
but they don't there's not that kind of
follow-through where you don't get that
feeling that they're relentlessly trying
to top themselves or want to and i'm i'm
generalizing like a john wick movie you
do get that center it is exhilarating
but i think a lot of these are like the
the gray man is the one that's popular
and and in this movie every single
action scene it feels like there are
elements in there that were just
creative in terms of like how do we up
the ante how do we make this bigger
better more exciting
yeah and it's so fun to see that that
constantly at play in everybody i would
say it wasn't just bigger because i
think that a lot of uh the comic book
films are especially guilty of this
where it's just
chaos on screen and it's just a million
different blobs shooting lasers no idea
what's going on you can't tell anything
until finally someone's like on the
ground it's like oh i guess that guy won
yeah right but this was so clear and the
the beats like escalated so clearly from
one from jumping out with a zoo full of
animals throwing the tiger at the other
guy then the other guy comes in and
flips the carriage over on fire and like
they just have this progression to them
and like maybe this is because they're
also musicals but they really had a
rhythm to them yes that i think is
missing from
western action cinema where like the use
of like one place i really noticed it
was at the beginning
um
that where he jumps into the crowd of
rioters to arrest one guy
and pulls him out like the way they used
um i don't even know enough about uh
filmmaking but like some kind of frame
rate tricks where it would go fast and
then slowly yeah speeding it up and then
slowing it down yeah but the way they
were doing that was mirroring like his
point of view and and i feel like that
like you see it when he gets back he's
he's finally like out of the uh of the
chaos and like it goes into slow motion
briefly and then he like slowly splashes
water on his face and then like takes a
breath and then
everything goes fast again because he's
like refreshed he's ready to fight again
it's like just moments like that it
worked with the character and with what
was happening at the moment it all just
it all came together in a very nice way
when i say think that's what i don't
necessarily mean like and then they
fight a bigger monster then the robot
comes out from behind the mountain or
it's like they think about ways in every
scene to make it more expressive to make
it more exciting to make it more
to grab you because even like the scene
we were talking about before we go to
the air where they introduce beam uh the
camera is upside down reflected in the
water in this jungle and then you like
turn on your side to see him and then
he's just fighting a wolf and then
attacking a tiger attacker and that's
just his introduction that's just like
let's what's what's this guy doing in
the jungle today let's catch up with him
yeah and like he rocks that uh tiger in
the face with like a poison dodge ball
it's just so good it's so good and he
apologizes he's like my dude yeah bad
i'm sorry and he's doing like the the i
don't know the like crossfit like cable
thing
and he's so strong that they snap that
was the moment where i was like oh
there's a lot of like
dive deep
we'll pull your last
ounce of strength you know like there's
a lot of those shots i feel like this
movie that's the first great one of them
this movie is the result of somebody
doing that spiritually yes
so let's all do that as we watch the
honors trailer for our our first but
hopefully not the last foray into south
asian cinema roll it
[Music]
you've seen this give
the ending of slumdog millionaire
and
um
okay look i'm american and i've never
seen a full indian film in my entire
life
but that all has to change now that i've
witnessed
r
r
r
so pause
um the uh we dropped the title very uh
early there but i love that this film
has the restraint did not reveal the
title until i think 41 minutes yeah
is when they finally build each r yeah
well yeah they build the rs aren't they
like layering in ours throughout
or it is in the intro like they do
like the do you get all ours in that
first 40 minutes yes because that's the
last of these that's the finals
are the actual r's
just
um no other film really earns the late
40-minute title droppers
it's like everything up until that is
kind of prolonged to the story they're
telling which is about this this
collaboration
turd betrayal turned
you know friendship of all time the two
best friends
yeah all right keep going
scrapped again for writer director ss
rajamouli's epic historical action
musical that proves beyond a shadow of a
doubt that american movies would be 10
times better if vin diesel and the rock
could do this
i would lose my mind
so pause yeah i mean imagine if you're
just watching a movie and like a
hemsworth and a mamoa just start doing
stuff like you'd lose your mind it'd be
amazing even if you had to like dub
their singing because that'd be asking a
lot of them too yeah i don't want to
hear mamoa well no offense but maybe
he's got a voice a voice of gold you
never know lenny kravitz is his best
friend yeah that's gonna have like a
gruff singer songwriter thing going on
you never know do you think that there's
anybody that could pull this off like an
american actor i think tom cruise could
do it
i got an answer for you right now his
name is hugh jackman hugh jackman but
tom cruise also would be the the he's
he's planning on doing him he and he and
i saw that
we were talking about doing we're
talking about movie music movies yeah
that'd be awesome i think channing tatum
obviously he will dance
his way oh yeah that's a good one
um that's a very good one yeah let us
know in the in the comments who if you
think could pull it off wait does does
emily blunt does she sing oh she sings
beautifully
because she's got action shots oh great
uh uh
oh she actually does the singing in um
oh nice that's her actual voice well
there you go uh
captain marvel too let's
let's do it i feel like we just cast it
i feel like we got the movie
all right keep going
i think so
we're instead of using vfx to cut down
on cars
they use it to make their stars do the
impossible
they had to put freaking oxen in the
disclaimer oxen
he wrote a zoo i follow the story and
how how is that not the best thing
you've ever seen in your entire yeah not
knowing that was coming was one of the
great joys uh of as a movie viewer um of
the year certainly um was not knowing
that that truck was full of a zoo and it
was it was it was teased we saw the
first animal and then they kept having
all that meat and all his friends were
like
you think you're gonna eat all that meat
and then it's like no that's tiger meat
son that's meat for tigers that's great
it was chekhov's meat yeah it's the
first verse maybe the first use of
chekhov's meat
yeah i mean and look the effects thing
like it doesn't look particularly real
because granted there's no like actual
comp that an animator can use for like
what would it look like if a human flung
a
a puma in a british soldier like it's
not realistic but it's stylish but it's
stylized and it's vibrant it's not like
a even though it's at night it's not
like a dimly lit grey blob um shooting
goo at another one um they shoot tigers
they should they throw tigers at each
other sir uh yeah i think i think so
often and this is it's a choice i'm not
saying it's like a like a a boo boo it's
like thing we're doing intentionally but
i think we're going for photo realism so
often in films that they'll do they'll
try to use like a lot of tricks and like
dull things out or sap the color away or
shoot everything on an overcast day or
digital smoke or something to like
cover their tracks so things
still look photo real lon they're doing
it because that's the moment where it's
the greatest it's a great morally great
right
and i think this movie they're never
like holding back because like well is
this gonna look 100 photo real it's like
it's gonna look awesome yeah so it
doesn't it doesn't so much matter if it
looks a little bit
fakey and stylized because it'll look i
mean it reminds me of yeah of the 80s
and 90s action movies where i feel like
the rule the special effects weren't
quite there they were just like well
what would be cool right what would look
the coolest and it's a little bit of you
wouldn't want it to look entirely photo
real because then you would feel bad for
the tiger that's being punched by flames
yeah like like the fact that he's
leaping into the tiger and punching it
but it looks kind of fake he makes it
awesome instead of like
oh
look at that tiger dude
it doesn't know where it is
good point all right keep going
of two real historical figures though
i'm pretty sure they never did this
together no they did they did
this this is based our true story
raju is a delhi police officer who's
always hot
so high he is a jungle warrior who's
always wet so fake
all hot and wet
bond grows so powerful it transcends
words
[Laughter]
yeah got it we have never met before
his two brothers in arms speak the
universal language of beatdowns
[Music]
dance battles
and casual horse versus motorcycle beach
racing that's just something they do in
an hour friends montage it's not even
part of the plot just beautiful stuff
man
pause
history i love an unmotivated horse
versus motorcycle chase
what a beautiful thing the motivation
was to show that they're friends
what do you do when you make a new
friend you get on your motorcycle you're
like grab your horse
and racing right now i'm a mechanic you
like horse stuff let's get this done
let's make this happen you know like
yeah yeah that was beautiful and it
totally glossed over um
i was confused how much they knew about
each other and when they when they found
out certain things like he never asked
beam never asked roger like what he did
for a living yeah he never was like what
do you do
like oh i'm an investigator i'm a cop
that never came up they're just too
focused on they're just their hobbies
just being friends being bugs just being
good friends saving kids
racing motorcycles and horses yeah i
mean look if you save a kid the way they
save a kid you have to be best friends
forever now there's no yeah i mean you
do yeah i what an amazing connection is
to see someone out of a crowd when
there's a drowning kid and just lock
eyes and be like
you and me we're saving this kid all
these other people don't know what to do
would me
this guy gets this guy get on your horse
which i know you have parked right over
there but you have a horse over there
i've got my motorcycle we're going to
recreate a counterbalance and it was the
way uh speaking of like the way the
action beats escalate it's like yeah
okay they have to save a kid uh yeah
okay they have to like dang like bungee
jump to do it but then you add like they
also have to go
safely through this wall of flame yeah
so that they're gonna dip a flag in
water and wrap each other and wrap the
other one in it so he can safely be like
a little wet burrito going through the
and they figured all this out
yeah they were putting this plan
together as they were running down it's
incredible that's that's their bond it's
like that they've got that uh jean grey
cyclops second report
i was also going to say before we
proceed uh the guy i believe jake is the
name of the character the the british
guy that they have the dance battle
against yes at the fancy party he's got
the greatest like i'm dancing as hard as
i can intense face i've ever seen like
he really sells you on the fact that
like this guy could not dance this guy
could not dance any harder than he is
currently dancing by the way if any
indian film producers are out there and
you need a second jake i am available i
will travel
i looked up this actor that this that
guy who plays jake is a a british actor
who works almost exclusively in indian
movies and he very often plays a
foreign guy who learns how to do the
bollywood dance like that's like his
niche yeah is he's the the guy who by
the end of the movie he can join in he's
our rapping grandma he's right he's like
they're cute like oh we taught this this
one white guy how to do our dances yeah
it's like a tyler perry play when the
white person shows up and it's like oh
now the white girl's gonna say exactly
that role in the tyler perry movie yes
that's it so living the dream got it all
right keep going
culture you probably have zero
non-racist references for but you've
seen enough michael bay movies to wonder
am i watching propaganda right now yes
this looks like captain america's uso
show oh for sure but whatever they're
saying to indians one message is clear
to the entire world
seriously the british as the brits range
from evil
[Music]
to demonic i want to see his neck drawn
out tight
and his eyes bulge and pop
just before his neck
snaps to holy sh that woman carries a
spike whip between her legs just in case
someone needs torturing aren't you quite
vicious my dear in a portrayal that's so
negative it got an actual englishman to
pin a rebuttal of mild annoyance my word
what an off-putting display
so pause
i will say broadly uh i the only thing
i'm more ignorant about uh than american
politics would be uh the rest of the
world's politics so i truly don't know
what's happening and i can tell this
movie was selling me on some nationalist
vision of something and i will only say
this uh just don't get your politics
from action movies yeah please don't
just bar none whether it's a
a regressive seeming beat in an american
uh michael bay film or it's uh uh
something else that you see in a in a
korean film that you're like huh this is
weird uh just get your politics from uh
other sources aside from aside from like
the cinema where somebody fights tiger
turns into a robot or if anyone if if
there's any bullet time uh don't learn
from it
don't learn anything we had to learn
this lesson the hard way in the 1980s
where uh you know the action movies were
not the most progressive it was not a
very liberal time
in filmmaking has it ever i think
there's inherently something about
action movies where it's like well let's
just kill everyone it's right it's baked
right in true
i think especially that's where we got
this like very raw rod jingoistic like
kill em all
america kind of kind of actually so i
think we grew up with that like listen
you can't necessarily take this at face
value
not to take it to facebook
yeah but uh yeah so for a new generation
i think we're really and it did teach me
by and large that like these things are
not um
i don't know uh uh uh insidious mind
poison that will turn you into the
protagonist right because i have yet to
become a renegade cop who doesn't play
by the rules even though given my
viewing habits from 1985 to 1995 that
would be my path i do cut my pizza
slices with a scissors like cobra like
coke i will say that yeah i actually
swap faces with nicole byer every once
in a while
let's take the face yeah take that face
off
but maybe i'm just a tango who hasn't
met his cash yet
you never know if you're out there uh
all right keep playing
settle in for a three-hour run time so
there's room for action dancing singing
politics and romance
none between the leads but yeah there's
definitely some tension there
like the romance between raju and sida a
girl who waited four years for her man
to pick up something from the store
yeah pause uh raj's plan
seemed like it had a few extra steps in
it considering it was
steal guns that wouldn't that sort of
boiled down to a steel gun yeah we need
guns now i don't want to i don't want to
get too into this because maybe this is
maybe this is the part that was from
history i don't know is he no none of
that these two guys later became like
after the period depicted in this film
they went on to become important figures
in the indian revolution uh nothing but
they did all that stuff together and
then became revolutionary nothing in
this movie is even like they didn't even
know each other yeah this is all just
complete fraud but i guess like on his
own he could have been a guy who like
armed the people
by becoming a british officer or
something i don't think any of that okay
i i would literally not take anything
that happens in this movie is like maybe
that happened no he just made up a bunch
of notes they just took the names this
is like it would be like you know like
when we do those parodies where it's
like what if george washington and
thomas jefferson were like the boys you
know like the seven or something right
this is like abraham lincoln vampire
hunter yes exactly
like they're taking their real
historical figures and making something
ludicrous turning them into superheroes
in a knowing way this is like a big
opportunity for um god who needs a hit
sony or something to do that to be like
we have the president verse or the the
historical figure verse where we're
gonna take like harriet tubman and helen
keller and they're gonna meet and
they're gonna kick so much ass together
oh my god the best and fastest of
friends
uh it's not you're you're joking but
you could sell this yeah yeah you could
actually say
it's not the worst idea i've ever done
all right keep playing gotta work on
that pitch
and the romance between beam and jenny a
story of how true love overcomes all
even not knowing a single word the other
person's saying i'm sorry i can't
understand what you're saying sorry oh i
wish i knew what you were saying i'm
sorry
jenny
oh i'm rooting for these two just be
careful about the in-laws yeah not a
word
strap in for the year's most eye-popping
crowd-pleasing spectacle that brings a
joy to action filmmaking not seen since
stephen chow or james cameron that will
have even the most jaded hollywood movie
dancing in the isles and rushing to
catch up on at least 50 years of tally
in bollywood films to see what they've
missed
yes happy diwali folks happy diwali i
think i like it here i love this guy
yeah
oh yeah uh so sure this is uh please
someone give us like a syllabus of uh
what to watch next who knows more than
we do that would be that would be very
helpful uh leave it in the comments
below um but uh yeah excited to watch
more and it did remind me that was my uh
closest comp to me was one of my
favorite action filmmakers stephen chow
i haven't seen much from him lately i
wonder what he's been doing but kung fu
hustle shaolin soccer yeah where it's
like it's just there's a joy to it he's
having fun and the people on screen are
having fun and the action is over the
top and it's not too serious but uh
it's it's just got a ton of heart um
it's got it's got a motor
he's trying to top himself he's trying
to he's trying to come up with the next
clever thing and then the next big thing
and like and it's not like oh well the
movie needs this part so i guess we'll
have them go chase through the yeah it
doesn't happen now here's the train and
it doesn't feel like an homage to eight
other things and like you gotta hit
these beats it feels like he's trying to
like do something you haven't seen
before granted for all i know this is
like uh you know a dime a dozen in india
like they're like oh this is a total
ripoff of of uh of of ppp yeah and then
send us that like
i want to watch all of you yeah uh all
right let's do starting
starring
raj against the machine
bread rule can melt steel beams
for village people
colonial war zone elsa from the last
crusade i did not see that coming
and you're summoning all your strings
like a dang dbz character
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
watch us get flagged for that
oh well
it's over 9000. do we import this movie
stunt coordinator to fix superhero
flicks over here and not just because
he's great because his name is king
solomon great name i love his muslim
name um yeah and also i think the music
whoever did the music their name is mm
cream again fantastic job on the names
the music was so good yeah cause it's so
sweet it's just like sweet songs about
like describing what the plot the scene
is well the song songs are great but i
really like the score especially raj's
like terminator 2 oh my god yeah his
theme song that was really like when he
becomes like his full like flaming
archer yeah it's his final form good
stuff yeah
um all right well thanks all for
watching we're not done yet n m cream
mmm cream and king solomon favorite
prince album
all i got is m m cream um so please
subscribe and like uh for i would
hopefully more like this in the future
hopefully more good films that we like
but not next week um
and uh also check out on this channel uh
our san diego comic-con playlist where
we did a whole bunch of fun comic-con
coverage and all those videos
oh the in the shadow what we do in the
shadows interview came up this morning
so um sorry what uh cbs's ghosts and cbs
is ghosts
um so check those out and uh check out
our twitch channel twitch.tv backslash
fandom where they're doing fun video
game stuff all the time from the os game
trailers folks and others
uh i don't know if we even have outtakes
for this maybe a few we have a we okay
we have a guest editor randy who did uh
uh superbly well well while our regular
editor kevin moves um so hopefully that
went smoothly but uh let's see if we
have any uptakes and see what those
might be
starring
fresh deli meat
rambo
let me see
bastard and commander
gone girl
which movie has the best human piggyback
fight this one or everything everywhere
all at once
good good choices excellent choices i
would say this one because there were
multiple piggyback
fights at moments they returned that was
like their signature move yeah this one
also has the move where uh like raju is
up top
shooting the gun yeah but then he'll
hand it off to beam who's carrying him
but also doing the reloading and then
passing the gun up that's an amazing
move and then when they do that thing
like where they fl like fling the other
one up the guard tower to punt the other
guy it was just great it's crazy um
keith frazier will the sequel to rr be
called r4 to r2r oh no i think it'll be
quest i think it'll be rrr i think they
got to add like
you know rise for bolt what is it rise
rinse repeat
repeat revolt revolt revengeance return
return yes
yeah
um
which western uh pericles dragon balls
asked which western action film would
benefit the most romantic musical
numbers i mean we joked about it it's
fast and the furious i think sure 100
you have luda in there
and i mean it's got it's got such a
clear like the theme is family so you
know what the songs are about it's like
we're we're following the rise and fall
of the toretto clan
it already is like a musical it starts
off almost like um in beauty and the
beast except like it's it's somebody um
preparing the barbecue for that day so
you're watching people like shucking
corn
and like weaving through all of the
various toretoes
exactly as this thing is getting is
getting set up i'm already writing this
and yeah and like you know the big like
race wars is coming everybody's prepping
for race wars like it already is like a
musical format exactly the other one i
was gonna say is like the godzilla
versus kong like a kaiju music a kaiju
musical but does godzilla sing i mean
okay okay that's that might break the
immersion just a bit that's what we're
saying
uh let's see um matanvalensky says how's
fi how feige isn't already uh sent to
emergency mode after rr combined with
the mixed reception and criticism of
laziness of phase four i don't know if
he's in emergency mode quite yet
because of our this movie made the craft
service budget of doctor strange too
let's not go nuts
but
uh i do think that uh they would be
foolish not to at least take some
pitches from this guy or just uh you
know indian film in general to be like
teach us to help us we we need a little
bit more fun
needs a spin-off where is our kingo solo
film oh man um yeah
we've got an avengers bollywood star
phone so keith frazier asks which mcu
movie should be remade in india this is
an interesting question because we were
just reading about forrest gump got
remade in india and we really want to
see that one very curious about how they
adapted that one for indian culture
an mcu movie in india i think it would
have to be eternals i think that um
zhao
uh excellent filmmaker um i think
eternals was not uh
the i think in
in this guy's hands eternals would be
great and give chloe zhao doctor strange
or something like that but i think that
uh the big expansive thing with god's uh
dancing
that's that's the one i would send to
india oh i would like to see the
celestials like get down like all of a
sudden you're you know you're at that
college in london and then you see like
the big celestial head and then he just
starts like popping and locking maybe
does the moonwalk and it's like okay
well i guess this is where i live now
yep i'm going to go with uh guardians of
the galaxy oh and it's already so
musically inclined to be like 70s
indian music that star-lord is into love
i feel like that would be like a whole
vibe of its own that'd be awesome um
let's see and uh finally james bunt if
they were to take over the fast and
furious franchise post vin what would
you call it i mean you can't there's no
is there any no
no mine is dom please he's gotta i mean
i know he's like a producer on all of it
he's gotta own some piece of that and
just say no you're never doing this
without me i ca it's so hard for me to
imagine i mean this is what like the
downfall of hobbes and shaw is that that
world without a vinless version of that
world just doesn't listen well that's
also like there's a vin shaped hole in
that world it's a and the only reason
they got that spin-off was because it
was a spike spinning like it was just
because it was like
there's more in your contract but i
would never like to see you again yeah
uh as evidenced by that uh barbecue
scene we put in yeah they won't look at
each other so bizarre i've rewatched
that like the the framing of that is
makes zero sense um
neither does next week's honest trailer
uh
hoo boy wow what a what a what a combo
what a back-to-back this'll be there's a
line there's a line in the movie where a
character says with with
disgust in their voice
he didn't say there'd be bugs and that's
my that's my case
that's my hand they did not say there
would be no they didn't and i was
greatly dismayed by how many there were
uh oh and then uh son rahmanian says
when are you starting global fandom
select me already
i'm not sure what for but you're in
you're selected you've been selected
i don't i don't know what we're doing um
but yeah we would love to cover more uh
um we say international because we're
the only country in the world everything
else is forward yeah like
foreign language films like you guys
watch we watch normal films you guys
watch foreign language films uh so yeah
i mean i i think that this was uh fun to
uh it's all i don't know if we've ever
done like a full
uh film that wasn't in english for an
honest trailer no i think it's just the
oscars
just when they're part of like an oscar
package or something yeah i guess i
can't think of a counter example to that
that's surprising but yeah so i would
love to uh i would love to assemble the
um
uh i guess the planeteers of the screen
ducky's planeteers to to try to get a
little more expertise what about the
antonioni's
for next week what do you guys think
done
done all right see you next week for la
clice uh this whatever that is um it's a
pleasure it's really good always a
pleasure uh we will see you next week
for
bugs
way more bugs than leaks so many and
they're so big
[Music]
you